emily is with us in green bay wisconsin
hi emily welcome to the show how can we
help
hi um so my husband and i got married in
november
and we've been talking about having a
baby
not right this very second but sometime
in the near future but
all these numbers that you see everyone
says it's so expensive like hundreds of
thousands of dollars
so and i'm a planner so i'm just
wondering how do we decide if
we are financially prepared for a baby
uh you are yeah i was about to say if
it's a hundred thousand dollars to have
a baby emily i'm never having a baby
those numbers are um are
stretched and they really mostly come
into play
if you get into a super large family but
if you have a couple of children the
vast majority of your electric bill does
not change
your water bill changes a little but not
that much
your food bill will change some but not
that much
first couple of years you got some
formula and diapers and other things
mandatory pediatrician bills that
uh come at you and that kind of stuff we
always joked and said it's
mandatory it's federal law in the first
three years of a child's life to pay the
pediatrician's porsche bill
but they they don't really make that
much money the pediatricians don't but
it's still fun to mess with them but the
um
uh yeah so you're gonna have some costs
but the idea that you need to have 200
000
in the bank before you have a child is
absolutely ludicrous no or will you
realize over the scope of their life
that you spent 200 000 on them no you
won't even realize it
because it's just like you know we get a
little bit more macaroni
we get a little bit more another
six-pack of coca-cola or whatever i mean
you just whatever it is that the family
eats they're just gonna eat it
and so you know if you're asking the
question out loud you probably can
afford it
okay yeah have a baby emily
we don't we do not have never in the
history of
ramsey solutions told someone to have a
child or not have a child based on
their financial situation yeah now
obviously you want to use common sense
and reasonableness and if you're
completely broke and you make
21 000 a year don't have 16 children
it's a problem
you know uh that kind of thing that's
common sense and reasonableness
but you know the typical middle class
family
doesn't have any trouble affording in
air quotes
of their children you're going to be
just fine i agree
i like that answer dave i'm proud of you
on that answer
well thanks i feel better about myself
but you know what dave i i have said
this so tell me if i'm wrong for saying
this i don't believe
in the first six months to a year you
should you should have a baby
of your marriage it should be spent with
y'all two getting to know each other and
figuring out what you're gonna do with
your life yeah that's not a financial
equation though
that's just a space equation and
you know most couples do that yes um but
other couples are um really excited to
have children
i know uh and and that's okay too if you
want to do that i
i we enjoyed a couple years like you're
talking about before denise came along
and um and we've enjoyed every year
since she came along as well
so um uh and none of them were her fault
one way or the other so that's you know
that
the first baby right but the um but yeah
anytime in any area of your life money
relationships anything you can give
yourself
margin yeah that's a good thing margin's
never a bad thing it gives you
kind of smooths out the waves of life a
little bit